this is a relationship that i don't
think anybody saw coming who are you
texting ken does his name rhyme with
feet
the new trailer for the kardashians new
hulu series just dropped and fans are
getting an inside look at kim's
relationship with pete davidson and her
split from kanye west
it's a different experience for sure the
41 year old kkw beauty founder recently
teased to variety that she's definitely
open to talking about her new
relationship and will definitely explain
it on the new show and from the looks of
it seems like she's making good on that
promise
this is a relationship that i don't
think anybody saw coming who are you
texting ken does his name rhyme with
feet
yeah from that little snippet it appears
cameras were rolling as kim hosted
saturday night live back in october
where she made headlines for puckering
up in this sketch with the 28 year old
comedian i like you just the way you are
now are you gonna kiss me or not
i sure am jasmine
yeah the two started dating after that
and have been going strong ever since
in fact last week the skims founder made
their love instagram official posting
these cuddled up snaps with the king of
staten island star at the end of the day
life is about being happy and in that
interview with variety kim says while
the two haven't filmed together yet
she's not opposed to it as for pete well
kim explains it's just not what he does
but if they were at an event together he
wouldn't tell the cameras to get away
who are you texting ken does his name
rhyme with feet
but the reality star isn't only opening
up about her new love
she's getting real about her estranged
husband and the father of her four
children kanye west it is really hard
with kanye he told me my career is over
why are we always making excuses for the
people that traumatize us of course kim
and kanye have been publicly feuding on
social media amid their ongoing divorce
with yay hurling a series of accusations
at kim on instagram and trashing her
nubo online and in song
god send me from that crash
just so i could beat pete davis
and while kim previously told variety
that fans shouldn't expect to see all
the behind-the-scenes drama on her new
show out of respect for their kids it
looks like the topic isn't totally off
limits
it is really hard with kanye the makeup
mogul previously told the mag quote i
believe in championing publicly and
criticizing privately i don't think i
would ever criticize the father of my
children on my tv show that's just not
really what i'm about i do have
you know a family that i have to just be
positive and get it together for and
while fans will just have to wait until
the kardashians premieres april 14th on
hulu to see how it all goes down
one thing's for sure this is a family
that sticks together
no matter what never go against the
family
never go against the family
[Music]
you